hey guys my name is Jess today is the
11th of November and you're watching
games but the latest updates from metal
gear solid 5 the phantom pain has made a
bunch of changes including allowing you
to reverse a major plot point in the
game's narrative will keep this GS news
episode spoiler free but at the very
least we can tell you that a character
that disappears from the game it can now
be brought back as for the non spoilery
changes the PF rating screen has
received a makeover with a new UI and
better readings of factors contributing
to your overall strength there's also a
host of new features for the Forward
Operating Base and metal gear online
modes as well as new measures to better
assist new players in both the
single-player and from line mode you can
check out the specifics of the story
change as other additions in our article
on gamespot the first three steam
machines are now available across the UK
and North America and here's a rundown
of them the ante on steam machine by
zotac will run you 800 US dollars and
includes an Intel Core i5 6400 tape or
gigabytes of RAM a terabyte of storage
and an NVIDIA 960 card starting at five
hundred and thirty bucks the side the
steam machine comes with an intel core
i3 processor in geforce gtx 950 two
gigabyte GPU a one terabyte hard drive
and four gigabytes of ddr3 memory the
higher end model goes for fourteen
hundred and fifty dollars and has an i7
CPU 16 gigabytes of ddr3 ram and an
nvidia gtx 980 four gigabyte graphics
card finally alienware is releasing a
line of steam machines ranging from a
basic four hundred and fifty dollar
model with an i three four gigabytes of
memory and a custom geforce gtx card
with two gigabytes of gddr5 the more
expensive premium model will run you 750
bucks and comes with an i7 processor 8
gigabytes of RAM and the same custom
geforce graphics card oh and steamer
having a steam machine launch
which discounts countless great pc games
so check that out finally despite
launching in a busy busy month
Activision have announced the call of
duty black ops 3 has been a big hit
generating five hundred million dollars
in its first three days launch the
publisher declared that this makes the
military shooter the biggest
entertainment launch of the year by
comparison halo 5 guardians made 400
million in its first week of release and
call of duty black ops 2 generated 500
million in its first 24 hours Activision
also revealed that total worldwide sales
for black ops 3 rose significantly from
previous instalments and that downloaded
copies for the game on consoles jumped
by nearly a hundred percent the
publisher said the black ops 3 players
logged more than 75 million hours online
from november six to eight the game also
scored a new record to become the ps4's
best selling digital single game by
units sold on its first day in the
history of console then we are down in
that comment section if you've sunk your
teeth into call of duty black ops 3 and
what you think of it so far you can add
the games but we've got stories on
Apple's performance on consoles and halo
5 multiplayer issues that is everything
I help you today but be sure to drop by
same time tomorrow for a bunch more new
you